hates particularly a conservative
government hates the idea that they they
should be censoring anyone online or
anywhere else and so the difficulty with
with both these units and with prevent
and and with that and in the states as
well is that these units generally
operate secretively they're kept quiet
for national security reasons and when
we asked why that not more information
had not been made available about these
units when we were writing the story the
government told us well for national
security reasons we try and try and keep
this stuff quiet well the question is
why are they doing that why shouldn't
the public know by what metric will you
decide whether or not what I say on
Twitter is is worthy of being taken down
or being flagged to social media
companies